Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Hoy, vamos a mirar el mundo de Roma
a través de los ojos de una niña.
Aquí está, dibujándose a sí misma
en el atrio de la enorme casa de su padre.
Su nombre es Domitia,
y tiene solo 5 años.
Tiene un hermano mayor de 14 años,
Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus,
que lleva el nombre de su padre.
Las niñas no tienen esos
nombres largos como los niños.
Lo peor es que papá insiste
en llamar Domitia a todas sus hijas.
"¡Domitia!"
Pide a Domitia que dibuje en la columna,
Domitia III.
Ella tiene una hermana mayor,
Domitia II de 7 años.
Y luego está Domitia I de 10 años.
Debería haber habido una Domitia IV,
pero mamá murió tratando
de darla a luz hace 3 años.
¿Confundidos?
Los romanos también lo estaban.
Podían trabajar la ascendencia
por parte de padre
usando esos lindos nombres tripartitos
como Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus.
Pero era un verdadero desastre
en el que Domitia se casó con un fulano
y era a su vez tía abuela
de la abuelastra de mengano, etc.
a la hora de volcar eso por escrito.
Domitia III no solo está
dibujando en la columna,
también está mirando la acción.
Como ven, es temprano,
en el momento del día en que todos
los clientes y amigos de su padre
vienen a verlo a casa
para tributarle respeto.
Lucius Popidius Secundus de 17 años,
que quiere casarse con Domitia II
en los próximos 5 a 7 años,
ha venido también.
Parece no cortejar a su futura esposa,
sino a su padre.
Pobre Lucius, no sabe que el papá de Domitia
piensa que su familia es adinerada
pero aun así canallas de Subura.
Después de todo, es la parte de Roma
llena de barberos y prostitutas.
De repente, todos los hombres
se van con papá.
Son las dos,
momento de estar en la corte
con una amplia audiencia de clientes
para aplaudir su retórica
y silbar a su oponente.
La casa ahora está más silenciosa.
Los hombres volverán en 7 horas,
no hasta la cena.
Pero, ¿qué pasa en la casa
en esas 7 horas?
¿Qué hacen Domitia, Domitia
y Domitia todo el día?
¡No es una pregunta fácil!
Todo los escritos romanos
que tenemos hoy fueron obra de hombres.
Esto dificulta la reconstrucción
de la vida de las mujeres.
Sin embargo, no podemos tener
una historia sólo de hombres romanos
por eso allá vamos.
Podemos empezar en el atrio.
Hay un enorme telar,
en el que la última esposa de papá
está trabajando en una nueva toga.
Domitia, Domitia y Domitia están atareadas
hilando la lana
que se usará para tejer
este poderoso manto,
9 metros o más de largo,
de forma elíptica.
A los romanos les encantaba la idea
de que sus esposas trabajaran la lana.
Lo sabemos porque lo escribieron
en las lápidas de muchas mujeres romanas.
A diferencia de las mujeres griegas,
las mujeres romanas salían de casa
y se movían por la ciudad.
Iban a los baños por la mañana
para evitar a los hombres
o a baños separados, solo para mujeres.
Algunas lo hacían para
estar a la moda del 70 AC:
bañarse desnudas con los hombres presentes.
Donde no tenían cabida
era cuando los hombres estaban:
en el Foro,
el Palacio de Justicia,
o en el Senado.
Su lugar en público son los pórticos
con jardines,
con esculturas
y con senderos para caminar.
Cuando Domitia, Domitia y Domitia quieren
dejar la casa para ir a algún lugar,
como el Pórtico de Livia,
deben prepararse.
Domitia II y Domitia III están listas,
pero Domitia I, que tiene compromiso de matrimonio
en dos años con el querido Filato,
no está lista.
No es que sea lenta,
sino que tienen más por hacer.
Estar comprometida implica
llevar la insignia matrimonial:
anillos de compromiso
y todos los obsequios que le dio Filato:
joyas,
pendientes,
collares
y colgantes.
Incluso puede llevar su corona de mirto.
Todo lo que diga a gritos:
"¡Me casaré con ese joven de 19 años
que me dio todo esto para que luzca!"
Mientras esperan, Domitia II
y Domitia III juegan con sus muñecos
que emulan la imagen de su hermana
engalanada para casarse.
Un día, estos muñecos serán ofrendadas
a los dioses del hogar en el día de su boda.
Bueno, ya estamos listos.
Las chicas suben a literas
llevadas por esclavos fornidos.
Junto a ellas también va una chaperona
e irán al encuentro de una tía
en el Pórtico de Livia.
Llevadas en alto, en las espaldas de estos esclavos,
las chicas miran a través de las cortinas
para ver las calles atestadas de gente allí abajo.
Atraviesan la ciudad, pasan el Coliseo,
pero luego doblan para subir la colina
hacia el Pórtico de Livia.
Fue construido por Livia, la esposa
del primer emperador Augusto,
en el sitio de la casa de Vedio Polión.
No era un gran tipo.
Una vez trató de alimentar con un esclavo
a las anguilas de su estanque de peces
simplemente porque dejó caer un plato.
Por suerte, el emperador estaba en la cena
y apaciguó su temperamento.
Las literas se colocan en el suelo,
las chicas salen,
y tomadas del brazo, de dos en dos,
suben los escalones
hacia el jardín cerrado por muchas columnas.
Domitia III salió disparada
y dibuja en una columna.
Domitia II la acompaña
pero trata de leer el graffiti
que está arriba en la columna.
Distingue un dibujo de gladiadores
y trata de imaginar que están luchando;
algo que a ella nunca se le permitirá ver,
salvo en la parte trasera del Coliseo.
Desde allí, tendrá una buena vista
de los 50 000 espectadores
pero verá muy poco de sangre y vísceras.
Si quisiera ver como corresponde,
podría convertirse en una virgen vestal
y se sentaría bien en el frente.
Pero una carrera al cuidado del
fuego sagrado de Vesta
no le agrada a todo el mundo.
Domitia I ha conocido
a otra niña de 10 años
también ataviada con las
insignias esponsales.
Hora de regresar a casa.
Cuando llegan después de las ocho,
algo está pasando.
Hay un plato roto en el suelo.
Todos los esclavos están reunidos en el atrio
y esperan la llegada de su amo.
Papá se pondrá loco.
No golpeará a sus hijos,
pero como muchos otros romanos,
cree que los esclavos deben ser castigados.
El látigo se encuentra listo para su llegada.
Nadie sabe quién rompió el plato,
pero papá llamará a alguien
que los torture, si debe hacerlo.
El portero abre la puerta de entrada a la casa.
Un silencio se apodera de los esclavos ansiosos.
No entra su amo;
en vez de eso, una adolescente embarazada.
Es la hija mayor del amo, de 15 años,
que ya es veterana del matrimonio y del parto.
Adivinen su nombre.
Hay una probabilidad de 5 en 10
de que no sobreviva al nacimiento del bebé,
pero por ahora viene a cenar con su familia.
Como madre adolescente
ha demostrado ser una esposa exitosa
al darle hijos y descendientes a su marido
que perpetrará su nombre en el futuro.
La familia va al comedor
y se sirve la cena.
Al parecer, papá ha tenido una
invitación a cenar en otro lugar.
Al terminar la cena las chicas cruzan el atrio
para despedirse de su hermana mayor
que volverá a casa en una litera,
escoltada por algunos guardaespaldas de papá.
Volviendo a la casa,
las chicas atraviesan el atrio.
Los esclavos, jóvenes y viejos,
hombres y mujeres,
esperan el regreso de su amo.
Cuando regresa, él puede vengarse,
asegurando que su poder sobre los esclavos
se mantenga a fuerza de violencia y terror,
a la cual cualquier esclavo puede ser sometido.
No obstante, las chicas,
van hacia arriba a pasar la noche,
se disponen a dormir.